it was trying and not fun to put your
brain where it has to go because there
is the Lawrence Olivier try acting dear
boys thing yeah which I get and we you
know we all appreciate that to whatever
extent but I'm the type of person where
I'm I don't know that I'm a good enough
actor to fake it I kind of have to think
about
uh
and killing in my head while doing the
lines and that's not that's I I know
there are going to be people that think
that's really uncouth and why and how
dare you and what's the point of going
there but it's like that's
that's what I do to entertain you and
make that character feel believable
without actually
exactly for the love of God it's not
like I'm one of those exactly but but by
the way there are these actors who are
like I'm gonna play a junkie so I gotta
try meth I'm gonna try heroin it's like
no you idiot like you don't have
to do that